وينضم الينا من تل ابيب مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام اهلا بك الياس ولنبدا
باجتماع المجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
الذي يفترض ان يلتئم اليوم والمعلومات
حوله
تفضل بالفعل خديجه ومن الواضح بان هذا
الاجتماع على قدر كبير من الاهميه ذلك انه
قد يحسم موقف اسرائيل فيما يتعلق
بالمقترحات المقدمه والتي سمع استمع اليه
الفريق الاسرائيلي خلال قمه باريس ديوان
رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيليه قال بان قمه
باريس كانت قدمت مقترحات بناءه كما وصفها
لكن في نفس السياق اشار الى ان ثمه فجوات
كبيره ما زالت هنالك حاجه للتجسير عليها
الان ال ديوان رئاسه الوزراء عاد هذه
الليله وقال بان المقترحات التي تناولتها
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه و مراحل اتمام
الصفقه ليست صحيحه وان هنالك كثير من
العمل يجب المضي فيه من اجل تحقيق صفقه
جديده لكن ما نشرته وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه تتحدث حقيقه هذه الصفقه عن
مراحل ثلاثه وهذه ال المراحل تبدا في
اعلان هدنه مدتها كما يبدو 45 يوما تتضمن
الافراج على 35 الى 40 اسيرا من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين داخل قطاع غزه اي
في مقدمتهم النساء والاطفال والمسنين
والمصابين المرحله الثالثه من الصفقه
تتحدث عن الجنود الاسرائيليين المحتجزين
والمرحله الثالثه تتحدث عن الجثث الموجوده
في الداخل والتقديرات في اسرائيل تشير الى
ان هنالك 40 جثه من بين الاسرى الذين
اسروا الى داخل قطاع غزه لكن ما الذي لا
تريده اسرائيل في هذا الاتفاق الذي لا
تريده اسرائيل هو اي تعا تعهد مكتوب يقول
بانسحاب اسرائيل من قطاع غزه ووقف الحرب
لكن في المقابل هنالك كما يبدو افكار
جديده او افكار خلاقه من شانها ان تقفز عن
هذه النقطه وهو ان لا يكون هنالك مكتوب في
هذا
الاتفاق ان عمليا ان توقف اسرائيل الحرب
او ان تواصل اسرائيل الحرب بمعنى اخر الا
يكتب الامران في هذا الاتفاق وبالتالي
تكون هنالك فرصه من اجل التفاوض في مراحل
في المرحله ربما الثانيه او الثالثه عن ت
تمديد الهدنه او وقف معين لاطلاق النار او
ربما التوصل الى صيغه تفاهم حول مقترحات
جديده تنهي هذه الحرب وكانت اسرائيل كما
تعلمين خديجه قد قدمت مقترحا في الاسابيع
الماضيه كان يقول اسرائيل ربما تكون
مستعده لوقف الحرب وانهائها فيما اذا سلمت
المقاومه الفلسطينيه سلاحها وخرجت اي خرج
قادتها خارج قطاع غزه لكن واضح بان هذا
الامر رفض من جانب المقاومه الفلسطينيه
جمله وتفصيلا الان هنالك ايضا قيود يحاول
شركاء بنيامين نتنياهو في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وضعها على الحكومه وتكبيل
بنيامين نتنياهو فيها في اطار اي هذه
الصفقه وهي تاتي من جانب الجناح اليميني
المتطرف في الحكومه الاسرائليه ايتمار
بنفير من ناحيه ووزير الماليه بيتسل ايس
مترش ايتمار بنفير وضعه خطوطا حمراء امام
بنيامين نتنياهو منذ اسابيع وقال له نحن
سنكون خارج الحكومه الاسرائيليه اي خارج
الائتلاف الحاكم اذا كانت صفقه تبادل
الاسرى ستشمل على اي تعهد من جانب اسرائيل
بوقف الحرب ووقف القتال في غزه وبالتالي
نتنياهو في مازق في هذه النقطه لانه في
نهايه المطاف يريد ان يحافظ على القاعده
الاساسيه والمهمه لحكومته قاعده الاغلبيه
التي تتالف منها الحكومه الان 64 عضو
كنيست على اعتبار انه يعلم انه في اليوم
الذي ستوقف فيه اسرائيل الحرب شريكه بيني
جانس في حكومه الطوارئ سوف ينسحب منها
شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام من سل ابيب